This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Man is a perpetually wanting animal. These are the words of Abraham Maslow, the psychologist, who in 1943 identified that humans have five basic needs. On the first and most basic level is the physiological need for food and water. The second need is shelter, a sense of safety and security. That's producer Avery Truffman. The third level is the need for love and belonging. Then the need for self-esteem and respect.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。人类是一种永远有所求的动物。这是心理学家亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的话，他在1943年指出人类有五种基本需求。第一个也是最基础的层级是生理需求，即对食物和水的需求。第二种需求是庇护所，一种安全感。这是制作人艾弗里·特拉夫曼。第三个层级是对爱与归属感的需求。接下来是对自尊和尊重的需求。
And then the last final stage of Maslow's hierarchy is the need for self-actualization, the desire for fulfillment and being all one can be. But it's not like Maslow's hierarchy is a video game. You know, just neatly complete each level as Maslow wrote. Most members of our society, who are normal, are partially satisfied in all their basic needs, and partially unsatisfied in all their basic needs at the same time. Which is to say, a complete gratification hardly ever exists for the wanting animal. Maslow said,
而马斯洛需求层次理论的最后一个最终阶段是自我实现的需求，即追求成就感以及发挥个人全部潜能的渴望。但马斯洛的需求层次并不是电子游戏。你知道的，正如马斯洛所写的，并非只需整洁地完成每个级别。我们社会的绝大多数正常成员，在所有基本需求上同时处于部分得到满足和部分未得到满足的状态。也就是说，对于这个有所求的动物来说，彻底的满足几乎从未存在过。马斯洛说，
A more realistic description of the hierarchy would be in terms of decreasing percentages of satisfaction as we go up the hierarchy. We will always have some hunger or another, and everything we want and desire in this world is a manifestation of one of these five basic needs. In Maslow's words, A desire for an ice cream cone might actually be an indirect expression of a desire for love. If it is, then this desire for the ice cream cone becomes extremely important motivation. Every day conscious desires are to be regarded as symptoms,
对需求层次更现实的描述应该是，随着我们向需求层次的上升，满足感的百分比在不断递减。我们总是会有这样或那样的饥饿感，而我们在世界上想要和渴望的一切，都是这五种基本需求之一的体现。用马斯洛的话来说，对一个冰淇淋甜筒的渴望实际上可能间接表达了对爱的渴望。如果是这样，那么对冰淇淋甜筒的渴望就会成为一种极其重要的动机。每天的显意识欲望都应被视为一种症状，
as surface indicators of more basic needs. Although sometimes the symptoms of our desires can be so much more complicated, so much more elaborate than an ice cream cone, and what we need manifests in strange and seemingly frivolous ways. Articles of interest, our pop-up show about fashion and what we wear is back. We'll be releasing episodes over the next four weeks
作为比基本需求更深层的表面指标。尽管有时我们的欲望症状会变得如此复杂，比一个冰淇淋甜筒精细得多，而我们的需求则以奇怪且看似轻浮的方式表现出来。我们关于时尚和日常着装的快闪节目《兴趣物件》又回来了。我们将在接下来的四周内发布单集，
on Tuesdays and the occasional Friday is kind of Tuesday, Friday, Tuesday, Tuesday, Friday, Tuesday. It'll be like the flag of Nepal, but upside down. Oh my God, so unbranded. It's hosted by Avery. And you don't need to listen to season one to understand season two. You can just dive right in. But either way, you're already listening to it now.
在周二以及偶尔的周五播出——有点像周二、周五、周二、周二、周五、周二。它会有点像尼泊尔国旗，但是倒过来的。天哪，太没有品牌标识了。由艾弗里主持。你不需要听第一季就能听懂第二季。你可以直接上手。但无论如何，你现在就已经在听了。
Articles of interest. A show about what we wear. Season two. People don't realize it's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mmm, that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore. How do you make money?
《兴趣物件》。一档关于我们穿什么的节目。第二季。人们没有意识到那是幻想。这总是你需要付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯，太棒了。再也没有人像国王那样穿衣打扮了。你是怎么赚钱的？
That's how I make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries. Linda Tessner wanted out. I did not love living in the middle west, the Midwest, and I really wanted to move. Linda went to Ohio State University for her master's in art history.
这就是我赚钱的方式，亲爱的。有很多我们视为理所当然的事情，曾经都被认为是奢侈品。琳达·泰斯纳想要离开。我并不喜欢在中西部生活，在中西部，我真的很想搬走。琳达在俄亥俄州立大学获得了艺术史硕士学位。
And when she graduated in the early 80s, she was ready to high-tail it out to New York or Boston. I wanted a museum job, but institution after institution, Linda was striking out. Then, one day, Linda was flipping through a newsletter for museum professionals, and she saw a job listing to be the director at a place in Washington State called the Maryhill Museum of Art. And I thought, what the heck is this?
当她在80年代初毕业时，她准备火速前往纽约或博尔顿。我想要一份博物馆的工作，但在一个又一个机构面试中，琳达都碰壁了。然后，有一天，琳达在翻阅一份针对博物馆专业人员的通讯时，看到了一则招聘启事，要在华盛顿州一个叫玛丽希尔艺术博物馆的地方担任馆长。我想，这到底是什么鬼？
And at the time, there was no internet in 1983, there was no way to kind of check it up or look at their website. I had no idea what this museum was about. But I sent them my materials anyway. Even though Linda was 26 years old and had never worked in museum management and didn't know this place at all, she got the job. And it was only then that Linda learned exactly where she was moving. Mary Hall Museum is in the middle of nowhere.
在当时，1983年还没有互联网，没有什么方法可以查阅它或查看他们的网站。我完全不知道这个博物馆是做什么的。但我还是把我的资料寄给了他们。尽管琳达当时26岁，从未从事过博物馆管理工作，对这个地方一无所知，但她还是得到了这份工作。直到那时，琳达才知道自己究竟要搬到哪里去。玛丽希尔博物馆位于荒郊野岭。
The closest town is Goldendale, Washington, which is 13 miles away. The Mary Hill Museum of Art is a stately mansion perched on top of a cliff by the Columbia River Gorge. It's stunning, but it looks like it was just cut and pasted onto the Lewis and Clark Trail. It has absolutely no other buildings around it. It's a very curious place because you drive to it, and the museum just unfolds like a castle on the banks of the river surrounded by basically nothing but hills.
离它最近的城镇是华盛顿州的戈尔登代尔，距离有13英里。玛丽希尔艺术博物馆是一座宏伟的豪宅，坐落在哥伦比亚河峡谷旁的悬崖顶上。它美极了，但看起来就像是被直接剪切并粘贴到了刘易斯和克拉克小径上。它的周围绝对没有任何其他建筑。这是一个非常奇妙的地方，当你开车前往时，博物馆就像河岸边的一座城堡一样徐徐展开，周围基本上除了群山什么也没有。
This is not what Linda was picturing when she got into the arts. She grew up reading fashion magazines, getting up on culture. Glamour was kind of my Bible for a long time. I mean, as a teenager, I read every single issue of 17 magazine, and then jump cut to Linda at 26 years old looking out over a vast expanse of the Columbia River. A friend of mine said that she gave me a year because I couldn't live with among cowboys. The Maryhill Museum of Art is surrounded by acres and acres of ranch land. Visitors usually found the museum by accident as they were driving back from ski trips.
这并不是琳达刚涉足艺术界时所想象的画面。她从小读时尚杂志，了解文化。《魅力》曾很长一段时间是我的圣经。我的意思是，作为一个十几岁的人，我读过《十七岁》杂志的每一期，然后镜头一转，26岁的琳达正眺望著哥伦比亚河的广阔原野。我的一个朋友说她只给我一年的时间，因为我无法和牛仔们生活在一起。玛丽希尔艺术博物馆周围环绕着大片大片的牧场。游客们通常是在滑雪回来时开车偶然发现了这个博物馆。
The closest thing to a restaurant was the nearest gas station. The closest building at all was two miles away. A small cottage owned by the museum. That's where Linda lived, mostly alone. Why were you alone? You moved with your husband. My husband was a research glaciologist, and he was on expeditions about nine months out of every year. So even before our marriage fell apart, I was living alone mostly.
最接近餐厅的地方是最近的加油站。最近的建筑也在两英里之外。那是博物馆拥有的一座小别墅。那是琳达住的地方，基本上是她一个人。你为什么是一个人？你不是和丈夫一起搬过去的吗？我丈夫是一名研究冰川学家，他每年大约有九个月都在外地考察。所以，甚至在我们的婚姻破裂之前，我也基本都是一个人生活。
So it was mostly just me living there with a big dog. Linda's big dog was her protector, barking at the rattlesnakes that appeared in her yard, and sometimes in her basement. I don't know, I was a brave person when I was 26 and stupid. As for the collection, what was actually inside the Maryhill Museum of Art, it was all over the place, as random and fascinating as its location. Because the whole museum was created as a lark, by four random, fascinating friends. The main founder was businessman Sam Hill. He's friend number one.
所以基本上就是我和一条大狗住在那儿。琳达的大狗是她的保护者，对着出现在她院子里、有时甚至在地下室里的响尾蛇狂吠。我不知道，我26岁的时候是个勇敢且愚蠢的人。至于藏品，玛丽希尔艺术博物馆里到底有什么，真是五花八门，和它的地理位置一样随性而迷人。因为整个博物馆是由四个随性而迷人的朋友作为一个玩笑创建的。主要的创始人是商人萨姆·希尔。他是1号朋友。
He began construction on this beautiful mansion in 1914 and named it Mary Hill. And there's some debate about whether he named it for his wife or his daughter because they were both named Mary Hill. Sam Hill roped in friend number two, Loey Fuller, a famous modern dancer, performance artist, and friend to the sculptor Roda. She helped bring in a collection of Roda's original casts to Mary Hill. The third friend was Queen Marie of Romania. She had met Sam Hill in his world travels,
他在1914年开始建造这座美丽的豪宅，并将其命名为玛丽希尔。关于他是以他的妻子还是女儿的名字来命名它，还存在一些争论，因为她们的名字都叫玛丽希尔。萨姆·希尔拉拢了2号朋友洛伊·富勒，她是一位著名的现代舞者、表演艺术家，也是雕塑家罗丹的朋友。她帮助将罗丹的一批原版铸件带到了玛丽希尔。第三位朋友是罗马尼亚王后玛丽。她在环游世界时遇到了萨姆·希尔，
and she is why the atrium of the Maryhill Museum of Art is full of beautiful Romanian furniture. And the fourth and most important friend, at least for Linda, was Alma DeBretville Spreckles. She was the wife of Adolf Spreckles, head of these Spreckles sugar company. When I was a little girl, the boxes of sugar in our kitchen
这也是为什么玛丽希尔艺术博物馆的中庭里摆满了漂亮的罗马尼亚家具的原因。第四位也是最重要的朋友，至少对琳达而言，是阿尔玛·德布雷特维尔·斯普雷克斯。她是斯普雷克斯糖业公司负责人阿道夫·斯普雷克斯的妻子。当我还是个小女孩的时候，我们厨房里的糖盒
were always Spreckles sugar. Alma became one of the museum's first trustees and foremost benefactors. Her donation to the museum collection would have the biggest impact on Linda's life. And it was a bunch of creepy dolls. I shouldn't say this, but it was, I thought they were the most macabre objects I'd ever seen.
总是斯普雷克斯糖。阿尔玛成为了博物馆的第一批受托人和最重要的赞助人之一。她对博物馆藏品的捐赠将对琳达的生活产生最大的影响。那是一堆诡异的玩偶。我不该这么说，但我当时觉得它们是我见过最毛骨悚然的物品。
When Linda got to Maryhill, she stumbled on a glass case full of these dolls. And they weren't like baby dolls. They were clearly supposed to be adults, but they were thin and skeletal and looked like they were out of the nightmare before Christmas. Some of them were taken apart, so you'd see the American, a wire American with a disembodied head. You'd see these parts, little shoes, little purses, these wire bodies, these very
琳达来到玛丽希尔时，无意中发现了一个装满这些玩偶的玻璃柜。它们不像是婴儿娃娃。它们显然被认为是成年人，但它们又瘦又像骨架，看起来像是《圣诞夜惊魂》里走出来的一样。其中一些被拆解了，你会看到一个美国玩偶，一个带着脱离身体的头部的铁丝美国玩偶。你会看到这些零件，小鞋子、小钱包、这些铁丝身体，这些非常
blank ghost-like faces. The dolls were 27 inches tall, about double the length of your forearm, and they all wore strange, dirty dresses and mismatched jackets, all bedraggled from years of volunteers playing with them and switching up their outfits. There were around 50 of these dolls displayed in the glass case, all just bunched up close together
空白且像幽灵一样的面孔。这些玩偶高27英寸，大约是前臂长度的两倍，它们都穿着奇怪、肮脏的衣服和不搭调的夹克，因为多年的志愿者玩耍和更换服装而显得衣衫褴褛。玻璃柜里大约展出了50个这样的玩偶，它们都挤在一起，
like they were on crowded bleachers. A bright fluorescent light flickered above them, accentuating their creepiness. Apparently there were about 100 more of these dolls in storage. Linda did not know what was up with these dolls, but she couldn't really dwell on it. Frankly, there were so many things that had to be done at Mary Hall. I mean, absolutely everything was in some sort of disrepair or dysfunction, everything. I mean, from the bathrooms to signage. So among the Rodas sculptures, the Romanian furniture, a large collection of indigenous art and a display of chess sets, there were the dirty dolls, hiling up against the glass showcase in the hall, collecting dust.
就像坐在拥挤的看台上一样。一盏明亮的荧光灯在它们上方闪烁，放大了它们的诡异感。显然，仓库里还有大约100个这样的玩偶。琳达不知道这些玩偶是怎么回事，但她没时间深究。坦白说，玛丽希尔有太多事情要做。我的意思是，绝对每样东西都处于某种失修或失调的状态，每样东西。我是说，从浴室到标牌。所以在罗丹的雕塑、罗马尼亚家具、大量原住民艺术藏品和国际象棋展示之间，是那些肮脏的玩偶，挤在大厅的玻璃展示柜旁，积满灰尘。
Until one day, when Linda got a call from a curator at the DeYoung Museum in San Francisco, she asked Linda if she could come to Maryhill because she wanted to see these dolls. And that was when Linda learned what she had on her hands. These dolls weren't supposed to be so macabre. Actually, they were kind of heroes in a way, because these dolls had saved French fashion. This is the end of German pride and power in Paris. It began with the fall of France, and now amid the cheers of the people,
直到有一天，琳达接到来自旧金山德扬博物馆一位策展人的电话，她问琳达是否可以来玛丽希尔，因为她想看看这些玩偶。也就是在那时，琳达知道了自己手上拿着的是什么宝贝。这些玩偶本不该如此毛骨悚然。事实上，它们在某种程度上算得上是英雄，因为这些玩偶拯救了法国时尚。这是德国在巴黎的骄傲与力量的终结。这一切始于法国的沦落，而现在，在人们的欢呼声中，
the Nazi has fallen. After four devastating years of Nazi occupation, Paris was liberated on August 25th, 1944. Feast of liberation, at the Paris Opera of Long-Rinaun and all through the city, the same sights and sounds. Estatic.
纳粹已经倒台。经过纳粹占领四年毁灭性的折磨，巴黎于1944年8月25日获得解放。解放节，在巴黎歌剧院的长里瑙和全城各地，都是同样的景象和声音。狂喜。
Peresians rejoiced in the streets. Some of them gathered up the ration tickets that had governed their lives and tore them into confetti. And this turned out to be a very bad idea, because the war was not over. They'd still need those ration tickets. In the aftermath of the occupation, more than 5 million French adults and children didn't have adequate shelter or food. Perreesions dressed in ratty, worn clothes walked and bicycleed through their dark city. The capital of light, of art, of culture was a shell of itself. If rated by its own people, then by a French division.
巴黎人在街头欢庆。有些人收集起统治了他们生活的配给券，把它们撕成五彩纸屑。事实证明这是一个非常糟糕的主意，因为战争还没有结束。他们仍然需要那些配给券。在占领结束后，超过50万的法国成年人和儿童没有足够的住所或食物。穿着破旧磨损衣服的巴黎人在他们黑暗的城市中步行和骑自行车。这座光明、艺术和文化的之都如今只剩下一个空壳。如果由它自己的人民来评估，然后由一个法国师评估。
If rated by a French division. During the course of World War II, Paris lost its position as the epicenter of contemporary fine art. That moved to New York City, the literary world also resented around New York. But Paris was determined not to lose its soul, or at least not to lose everything to New York Somehow even though they didn't have electricity
如果由一个法国师评估。在第二次世界大战期间，巴黎失去了其作为当代纯美术中心的地位。这个中心转移到了纽约市，文学界也重新围绕纽约展开。但巴黎决心不失去其灵魂，或者至少不把一切都输给纽约。不知何故，尽管他们没有电，
Paris had to remain a capital of beauty and ideas It had to retain its title as the capital of fashion Look at it this way France has been relying on The couture industry and all of the other industries it involves, the textile industry, the industry that makes all of the zippers, the buttons, the hooks, the feather workers, the embroiderers. This is Melissa Levinton, an independent curator, fashion historian, and appraiser. That's been a big part of not only France's economy, but France's national identity since
巴黎必须继续成为美丽与思想之都。它必须保留其时尚之都的称号。换个角度来看，法国一直依靠高级定制行业以及它涉及的所有其他行业，纺织业、制造所有拉链、纽扣、挂钩、羽毛工、绣工的行业。这是梅利莎·莱文顿，一位独立策展人、时尚历史学家和估价师。这不仅是法国经济的重要组成部分，也是自
the 17th century. They're not just going to let that go because of four-year occupation by Germany. They were not going to let it die without a really tough fight. Before the war, in 1939, the French-fashioned industry employed more than 900,000 people. It was the second largest industry in France. And then by the end of the occupation, Paris fashion houses were just gasping for breath. They had no customers, and no materials. At all, everything had gone to the war effort.
17世纪以来法国国家认同的重要组成部分。他们不会仅仅因为德国四年的占领就放弃这一点。他们不会不经过一场真正艰苦的战斗就让它消亡。战前的1939年，法国时尚行业雇佣了90万名员工。它是法国第二大产业。而在占领结束时，巴黎的时装屋正奄奄一息。他们没有客户，也没有材料。什么都没有，一切都为了战争贡献出去了。
Shreds of leather and buttons were rare. Even spools of thread were few and far between. And this was really hard for France. I mean, the country has a department of its government devoted to regulating high fashion. It's called the Shambharsindra Kaldelakatur, and even in that post-occupation scarcity, the Shambharsindra Kaldelakatur wanted a send of message to the world. We are still here. We were not destroyed by the war, and we kept our skills. And we might not have much in the way of materials, but we're just going to figure it out. We survived, and we want you to know that we survived, but in order to keep going, we need our customers back.
皮革碎片和纽扣都极为罕见。就连线轴也寥寥无几。这对法国来说真的很艰难。我的意思是，该国有一个政府部门专门负责监管高级时装。它被称为高级时装工会，即使在占领后的物资匮乏时期，高级时装工会也想向世界传达一个信息。我们依然在这里。我们没有被战争摧毁，我们保留了我们的手艺。我们在材料方面可能没有太多资源，但我们会想办法的。我们幸存下来了，我们想让你知道我们幸存下来了，但为了继续走下去，我们需要我们的客户回来。
And the Shambharsandicol came up with an idea. They would gather all the famous French fashion designers together to do a joint fall collection. They would use real fur, real leather, real silk, no compromises. Well, except that everything would have to be in miniature. That way they could scrape together just enough to make tiny outfits, tiny shoes, little purses and gloves and belts, and still use real materials. So they revived an old, old French practice.
高级时装工会想出了一个主意。他们将召集所有著名的法国时装设计师一起制作一个联合秋季系列。他们将使用真皮、真皮、真丝，不作任何妥协。好吧，除了所有东西都必须是微型尺寸。这样，他们就可以凑集刚好足够的材料来制作微型服装、微型鞋子、小钱包、手套和皮带，同时还能使用真正的材料。于是他们复兴了一个非常非常古老的法国传统。
Fashion dolls. So let's talk about fashion dolls. The way dress makers and women who were called milleners marchandemod, kind of like fashion stylists of today, they sent around dolls. Dressed in the latest fashion, dolls were, in effect, the first catalogs. Clotheers were sending out dolls to wealthy families and royal circles way before the first fashion magazine came out in the late 1700s. So the Chambresondicaul decided to use dolls again.
时装娃娃。那么让我们来谈谈时装娃娃。服装制作师和被称为女帽商、时尚造型师的女性们，会将娃娃送到各处。身着最新时尚的娃娃实际上就是最早的目录。早在18世纪后期第一本时尚杂志问世之前，服装商就已经将娃娃寄给富裕家庭和皇室圈子了。因此，高级时装工会决定再次使用娃娃。
They reached out to fashion houses like Balenciaga and Nina Ricci and Hermes, and they each volunteered to create an outfit or two. The project was organized as a fundraiser for war refugees and victims, but it was also an advertising campaign, marketing the concept of French chic. The collection of 228 fashion dolls would be called the Tiattre d'Alemmeud, the theater of fashion, and they would be sent to the major cities across Europe and eventually America, and each showing would announce to the world that the Couture houses in France were still
他们联系了巴黎世家、莲娜丽姿和爱马仕等时装屋，每个时装屋都自愿设计一两套服装。这个项目被组织为一个针对战争难民和受害者的筹款活动，但它也是一个广告活动，营销法国时尚的概念。这套由228个时装娃娃组成的系列被称为时尚剧场，它们将被送到欧洲各大城市，最终到达美国，每一次展览都将向世界宣告法国的高级定制时装屋仍在
in business. That Paris was still the capital of glamour and luxury, even though the city barely had power. And okay, so I keep calling them dolls, but I'm wrong, they are not technically dolls. We have dolls enthusiasts who are like, we want to see the dolls, you can see the mannequins. This is collection's manager Anna Goodwin, showing me some of the Teatro de la Mode mannequins.
营业中。巴黎依然是迷人和奢华之都，尽管这座城市几乎没有电力。好了，所以我一直叫它们娃娃，但我错了，它们严格意义上不是娃娃。我们有娃娃爱好者会说，我们想看娃娃，你可以看看人体模型。这是藏品经理安娜·古德温，正向我展示一些时尚剧场的人体模型。
We definitely, at least I definitely cringe any time someone calls them dolls. These mannequins were sculpted by the artist, Elian Bonabelle, and they are works of art in and of themselves. They were intentionally made with wire limbs on those blank plaster faces, so that they would have no personality of their own. Absolutely. That was their goal was to create a mannequin that just disappeared. They look like sketchbook drawings brought to life.
每当有人叫它们娃娃时，我们绝对、至少我绝对会畏缩。这些人体模型是由艺术家埃利安·博纳贝尔雕塑的，它们本身就是艺术品。它们故意用铁丝四肢搭配那些空白的石膏面孔制作，这样它们就不会有自己的个性。绝对的。他们的目标就是创造一个人体模型，让它隐形。它们看起来像是活过来的速写画。
The wire limbs look like 3D brush marks. sketchbook drawings brought to life. The wire limbs look like 3D brush marks. The focus is obviously supposed to be on the impeccable clothes. Like this dress Anna showed me in storage. It sort of has a bodice with buttons and a collar and then it comes down to the waist where there's a belt which you can see is actually a functional belt. It's like a teeny tiny belt. It's about the buckles about half an inch by quarter inch. These are not doll clothes.
铁丝四肢看起来像是3D笔触。速写画活了过来。铁丝四肢看起来像是3D笔触。焦点显然应该放在无可挑剔的衣服上。比如安娜在仓库里向我展示的这件衣服。它有点像带有纽扣和衣领的紧身胸衣，然后延伸到腰部，那里有一条腰带，你可以看到它实际上是一条功能性腰带。它就像一条极小的腰带。扣子大约是半英寸乘四分之一英寸。这些不是娃娃的衣服。
There's no velcro, no fake snap-on attachments. These are real outfits. With little clasps and right-proper lining. I mean they look like runway or red carpet looks put into a shrinking machine. It kind of feels like when you look at a freshly born baby and you're like, oh my god, the little fingernails. Like everything is there. All in proportion. But so careful and tiny. Tiny little buttons there. Oh my god god those tiny buttons on the sleeves and let me tell you these fashions from 1945 and 46 are not what you're imagining like when I think 1940s fashion I think broad shoulders pencil skirts muted colors practical low-heeled wartime attire no these are rich full-skirted affairs with sumptuous overcoats
没有魔术贴，没有假的按扣附件。这些是真正的服装。带有小搭扣和真正的内衬。我的意思是它们看起来像是被放进缩小机里的T台或红毯造型。这有点像当你看着一个刚出生的婴儿时，你会觉得，天哪，那些小指甲。就像一切都在那里。比例完美。但又那么小心翼翼、小巧玲珑。袖子上有微小的纽扣，天哪，袖子上的那些微小纽扣，我得告诉你，1945年和1946年的这些时尚并不是你想象的那样，当我想到1940年代的时尚时，我想象的是宽肩、铅笔裙、柔和的颜色、实用的低跟战时服装，不，这些是奢华的大摆裙装，配有华丽的外套，
and gowns intricately beaded with thousands of tiny sequins and hair resplendent with exotic bird feathers. There are tiny, radiant sun dresses that hint at the 1950s to come, and dramatic pleated trousers that I would wear now. And the shoes do not get me started on the shoes. These are like white leather platform oxfirts, I guess, with a tiny buckle. Oh my God. And like just the stitching is minute. The Tiača Dela Mode premiered in March of 1945,
和礼服，上面密密麻麻地镶嵌着数千个微小的亮片，头发上点缀着异国情调的鸟羽。有微小的、散发光芒的太阳裙，暗示着即将到来的1950年代，还有我现在也愿意穿的戏剧性的打褶裤子。至于鞋子——别让我开始聊鞋子。这些就像是白色皮革厚底牛津鞋，我猜，带有一个小搭扣。天哪。而且光是缝线就极其细微。时尚剧场于1945年3月首演，
in the West Wing of the Louvre. It was a massive success. Supposedly, the installation in Paris raised something like a million French francs, which was a lot of money given the total economic disaster that was France after World War II. As the Tiatradella Maud opened, in March of 1945, Allied armies were pushing deeper into Germany, liberating French war prisoners. In April of 1945, France discovered the existential
在卢浮宫的西翼。这是一场巨大的成功。据说，在巴黎的装置艺术展筹集了大约一百万法国法郎，考虑到二战后法国彻底的经济灾难，这是一笔巨款。随着时尚剧场在1945年3月开幕，盟军正在深入德国，解放法国战俘。1945年4月，法国发现了集中营的生存
horror of the concentration camps. Bleakness was enveloping Europe, and the Tattardella mode was a tiny shred of pleasure. The show was extended for weeks and weeks. This miniature beacon of glamour attracted a hundred thousand visitors who paid what little money they had to witness this luxurious vision of what Paris still was in their imaginations, and maybe could be again. The Louvre's exhibit of the Teatro de la Mode ended around the same time that the Warded, in May of 1945. And so, the Teatro de la Mode went on to the next phase of its mission. The show, rebranded in English as a fantasy of fashion, was packed up and shipped to London,
恐怖。阴暗笼罩着欧洲，而时尚剧场是一丝微小的快乐。展览延长了整整几周。这座迷人的微型灯塔吸引了十万名游客，他们花着仅有的一点钱，来见证巴黎在他们的想象中曾经是什么样、也许还能再次成为什么样的奢华愿景。卢浮宫的时尚剧场展览结束的时间大约是在1945年5月战争结束的时候。于是，时尚剧场进入了其使命的下一阶段。这个在英语中被重新命名为“时尚幻想”的展览被打包运往伦敦，
then leads Barcelona, Copenhagen, Stockholm, and Vienna, all to rave reviews. And then, the little mannequins went to show off to the old rival, New York City, The little mannequins went to show off to the old rival, New York City, to more rapturous crowds. Garing did his best to strip the French style capital of its finest treasure, but there seems to be some things he missed. Certainly pretty snazzy. It looks like it was really worthwhile, freeing Paris. In 1946, the Tiatradella mud made its final stop, the D'Young Museum in San Francisco.
然后是利兹、巴塞罗那、哥本哈根、斯德哥尔摩和维也纳，都获得了极佳的评价。然后，这些小模特去向老对手纽约市炫耀了，小模特去向老对手纽约市炫耀，赢得了更多狂热的人群。戈林尽了最大努力剥夺法国时尚之都最精美的宝藏，但似乎有些东西他漏掉了。当然挺时髦的。看起来解放巴黎真的很值得。1946年，时尚剧场迎来了它的最后一站，旧金山的德扬博物馆。
And everyone agreed this would be the exhibit's final resting place. France didn't want the mannequins anymore. They didn't need them back. So the de Young had not earmarked funds to return them, like there was no spare cash in the system. The Tiazzadella mode was sent to a department store in downtown San Francisco that was named confusingly the city of Paris. I remember talking to a woman who used to work in the city of Paris, saying she remembered seeing them in the basement. And the mannequins just stayed in the basement in the city of Paris, saying she remembered seeing them in the basement.
每个人都同意这将是该展览的最终归宿。法国不再想要这些模特了。他们不需要它们回来了。所以德扬博物馆没有拨出资金将它们运回去，因为系统中没有多余的现金。时尚剧场被送到了旧金山市中心的一家百货公司，名字令人困惑地叫作“巴黎之城”。我记得跟一位曾在“巴黎之城”工作过的女士谈过，她说她记得在地下室看到过它们。而这些模特就这样留在了“巴黎之城”百货公司的地下室里，她说她记得在地下室看到过它们。
And the mannequins just stayed in the basement of the city of Paris department store for years. Until they were found by a wealthy San Francisco named Alma DeBretville Sprinkles. In 1952, she shipped them off to her pet project, a museum in rural Washington state. They were sent without any accompanying documents or explanation as to their origin. Perhaps Alma thought these mannequins needed no introduction, that everyone would, of course,
这些模特在“巴黎之城”百货公司的地下室里一呆就是多年。直到它们被一位名叫阿尔玛·德布雷特维尔·斯普雷克的旧金山富豪发现。1952年，她将它们运到了她最钟爱的一个项目中，即华盛顿州乡村的一个博物馆。它们被运送时没有任何随附文件或关于其起源的解释。也许阿尔玛认为这些模特不需要介绍，每个人当然都会，
remember this worldwide sensation, even though, of course, they didn't. In a lot of ways it seems to be the fate of this exhibition to get forgotten about, from time to time. France pretty much forgot about the Tiazzadella mode too. The mannequins were generally assumed to be lost or destroyed. But as you know, they weren't. The Tattadella mode was perched on a mountain top overlooking the Columbia River Gorge, with Linda.
记住这个轰动全球的盛事，尽管他们当然没有。在很多时候，被遗忘似乎成了这个展览的宿命，隔三差五就会发生。法国也差不多把时尚剧场给忘了。人们通常认为这些模特已经丢失或被毁了。但正如你所知，它们并没有。时尚剧场坐落在俯瞰哥伦比亚河峡谷的山顶上，和琳达在一起。
Really soon, after I started at Mary Hall, I got this call from a woman named Anna Bennett, who was the textile and costume curator in San Francisco. And she wanted to know if she could drive out to Mary Hall Museum and take a look at the Tattledella mode. It was like somebody walked into the museum and provided information that had been missing for a very long time. When this curator rediscovered the mannequins in the 80s, word traveled around academic fashion circles. A slow trickle of curators and professors and editors made pilgrimages to Maryhill,
在我开始在玛丽希尔工作后不久，我就接到了一个叫安娜·贝内特的女性的电话，她是旧金山的纺织品和服装策展人。她想知道自己是否可以开车去玛丽希尔博物馆看一看时尚剧场。这就像有人走进博物馆，提供了缺失了很久的信息。当这位策展人在80年代重新发现这些模特时，消息在学术时尚界传开了。一小波策展人、教授和编辑开始前往玛丽希尔朝圣，
each one adding a little more to the pool of knowledge. But then finally, the news got to Susan Train, the Paris Bureau Chief for Condé Nast. She was a woman that wielded a lot of power. She was very interested in fashion. She'd been in the fashion industry for her entire life. At the time, I met her, she must have been in her 50s, late 50s, maybe. Of course, Susan trained new all about the Tiatradella mod.
每个人都为知识库增添了一点新内容。但最终，这个消息传到了《康泰纳仕》巴黎分社社长苏珊·特雷恩耳中。她是一个很有权势的女性。她对时尚非常感兴趣。她一生都身处时尚行业。当时我认识她时，她一定有50多岁，快到50岁末了，也许吧。当然，苏珊·特雷恩对时尚剧场了如指掌。
And she knew it's important, and she couldn't believe that it was, like, there was this time capsule, there was this collection sitting in where, like, Goldendale Washington, what? Susan flew from Paris to the Pacific Northwest to see the mannequins. And was she wearing heels when she touched down at the Portland Airport? Yeah, F***. She always wore heels and always wore purls with her blonde hair chopped in a chic bob. Oh, and she always carried a pure, red, long-haired American Kennel Club doxened with her. Linda remembers she had one named Naphofia, which is a flower I had to look at. She was, uh, she was very intimidating because she was a very tall, thin, elegant, very
她知道它的重要性，她简直不敢相信，就像，有这样一个时间胶囊，有这样一个藏品坐在哪里，华盛顿州的戈尔登代尔，什么？苏珊从巴黎飞到太平洋西北地区来看望这些模特。当她在波特兰机场降落时，她穿着高跟鞋吗？对，废话。她总是穿着高跟鞋，金色的波波头梳得一丝不苟，还总是戴着珍珠。哦，她身边总是带着一只纯血的、长毛的美国养犬俱乐部腊肠犬。琳达记得她有一只叫内芙洛蒂亚，那是一种我不得不去查的植物。她，呃，非常令人生畏，因为她是一个非常高挑、消瘦、优雅、非常
elegant woman. Linda tried to roll out the red carpet as best she could. She took Susan to the only place you could eat out for dinner, which was a truck stop across the river called Jack's Fine Foods. This was a woman that, I mean, I'm sure, that a French fry rarely crossed her lips. And when Linda took Susan to the Maryhill Museum to see the Tiatra de la Mode, Susan adored it. She could see past the grime and the mismatched outfits
优雅的女性。琳达尽量铺红地毯来欢迎她。她带着苏珊去了唯一能吃晚饭的地方，那是河对岸一个叫杰克斯美食的卡车司机餐厅。这是一个女性，我的意思是，我确信，薯条极少进过她的嘴唇。当琳达带着苏珊去玛丽希尔博物馆看时尚剧场时，苏珊非常喜爱它。她能透过污垢和不搭调的衣服看到它们，
and recognize what it once had been. And she looked at the Tiatra de la Mode and she fell in love. It was kind of love at first sight. And there was another love blossoming between Linda and Susan. Not in a romantic way. Maybe it was an older sister, younger sister relationship.
并认出它曾经的模样。她看着时尚剧场，坠入了爱河。这有点像一见钟情。琳达和苏珊之间也萌生了另一种爱。不是浪漫的那种。也许这是一种姐姐和妹妹的关系。
Listen, you can hear it in Linda's voice. She wore these big earrings that were cut glass, but was like a big chunk of rock on her ear. And they were so shockingly beautiful to me. I'd really never seen anything like that. I remember once at lunchtime, I was saying, oh, Susan, I really, those earrings, I just, I just love them. And she immediately popped them off her ears and handed to the incident. I want them to, I want you to have them. She was generous like that. She was extremely generous. I mean, how could you not be completely taken with this glamorous person?
听着，你可以从琳达的声音里听出来。她戴着那种切割玻璃的大耳环，就像耳朵上挂着一大块岩石。对我来说，它们是如此令人震惊的美丽。我真的从未见过那样的东西。我记得有一次在午餐时，我说，哦，苏珊，我真的很喜欢那些耳环，我只是，我太喜欢它们了。她立刻把它们从耳朵上摘下来，递给了我。我想把它们，我想让你拥有它们。她就是那样慷慨。她极其慷慨。我的意思是，你怎么能不完全被这个迷人的人迷住呢？
It's the same thing that drew a hundred thousand starving French people to stare at the Tiatradella Maud. Glamour and luxury are powerful. Susan knew she had to bring these mannequins back to Paris. To revive the Tiatradella Maud back to its former glory. Sheins back to Paris to revive the theater de la mode back to its former glory. She went back to Paris and got busy. Susan did her Paris condy-naspir-achief thing and pulled together an elite team to refurbish the theater de la mode. There were moth holes and the mannequins themselves, some of them had to be resoldered and somethings
这和吸引成千上万饥饿的法国人盯着时尚剧场看的东西是同一个。魅力和奢华是强大的。苏珊知道她必须把这些模特带回巴黎。让时尚剧场恢复其昔日的辉煌。她回巴黎去让时尚剧场恢复昔日的辉煌。她回到巴黎开始忙碌起来。苏珊发挥了她作为《康泰纳仕》巴黎分社社长的作风，召集了一支精英团队来翻修时尚剧场。衣服上有虫洞，模特本身，其中一些必须重新焊接，有些东西
had to be recreated. And then maybe the most vexing thing was that well well, meaning volunteers over the years had changed all the clothes. So they were in no way, were they in their original ensembles. This was a team effort from a crew of set designers, clotheers and historians. Experts and artists referenced the black and white photographs from the original show and talked with the fashion houses to make sure the outfits were perfectly restored. Leather was polished, silk was dry cleaned, diamond jewelry was reconstructed, real hair
必须重新制作。然后也许最让人头疼的事情是，善良的志愿者多年来更换了所有的衣服。所以它们绝不是最初的服装。这是一支由布景设计师、服装师和历史学家组成的团队的共同努力。专家和艺术家参考了最初展出的黑白照片，并与时装屋进行了沟通，以确保服装得到完美修复。皮革被抛光，丝绸被干洗，钻石首饰被重构，真发
replaced and combed, and once again, the Shambhasa Inda Caldelecatur was footing the bill. The cool thing was that many of the original artists and designers who worked on the project in the 40s were still alive to oversee the revival in the 80s. This labor of love they all thought they had lost. And if the mannequins were going to Paris, Linda had to go with them. She had to ensure they were safe because they were still in the Maryhill collection. But also, there were many parties and celebrations to attend. Well, I remember I had bought outfits for all of these events that were taking place in Paris.
被替换并梳理，高级时装工会再次为此买单。最酷的是，许多在40年代参与该项目的原艺术家和设计师在80年代仍然健在，得以监督这场复兴。这是一项他们都以为已经失去了的爱的劳动。如果模特要去巴黎，琳达必须和她们一起去。她必须确保她们的安全，因为她们仍然属于玛丽希尔藏品。而且，还有许多派对和庆典要参加。嗯，我记得我为在巴黎举办的所有这些活动买过衣服。
And I thought I knew what I was doing, but the minute I got to Paris, the minute I got to Paris, Susan wanted to, like, what did you bring? So I took all of the clothes that I brought from home to her apartment one Saturday, and she was like, no, no, no. There was nothing wrong with Linda's look. The Susan was just on a whole other level. I ended up because she did so disapproved of what I had brought from Oregon. I ended up wearing a lot of her clothes to these events.
我以为我知道自己在做什么，但一到巴黎，我一到巴黎，苏珊就想，比如，你带了什么？所以在一个星期六，我把从家里带的所有衣服都拿到她的公寓，她就像，不，不，不。琳达的穿着并没有什么不对。只是苏珊处于完全不同的层面上。因为她非常不赞成我从俄勒冈州带的东西，我最后在这些活动中穿了很多她的衣服。
I think it was important to her that I looked a certain way and I certainly did not want to disappoint her. For the next two years, as the mannequins were being fixed up, Linda went back and forth, from Paris to Goldendale, from Champagne Toast to Rattlesnakes, and back again. Little by little, she was becoming more glamorous under the tutelage of Susan Train. Whenever I came to Paris, Susan always made sure there were flowers in my hotel room when I arrived. The most astonishing bouquets, like a profusion of pink lilies,
我想对她来说，让我看起来有某种特定的样子很重要，而我绝对不想让她失望。在接下来的两年里，随着模特们被修复，琳达在巴黎和戈尔登代尔之间来回奔波，从香槟祝酒到响尾蛇，再来回往复。在苏珊·特雷恩的指导下，她一点一点地变得越来越迷人。每当我来到巴黎，苏珊总会确保我到达时酒店房间里有花。最惊艳的花束，比如一团粉红色的百合花，
she arranged for me to have my hair done. She arranged for me to have my makeup done. She arranged for me to have a pearl choker made. Made? Made. She actually marched me, like, she just put me in the car with her driver and she would come along with her little dog And there was a jewelry story so I just know I know just where I need to take you for a pearl choker
她为我安排了做发型。她为我安排了化彩妆。她为我安排定做了一条珍珠颈链。定做？定做。她实际上带头，就像，她只是把我塞进她司机的车里，然后她带着她的小狗一起来，那里有一家珠宝店，所以我只知道，我知道我需要把你带到哪里去做一条珍珠颈链。
It was a real classic makeover montage. I actually have a scrapbook. I could pull out and show you. Could you? Yeah, Linda has kept nearly every party invitation every every dinner menu. And in her scrapbook, there are lots and lots of photos. And Linda looks like a supermodel. She's tall and thin with blonde, bobbed hair, and her three strand pearl choker. Always with a drink in hand, flushed with laughter. The Tiatra de la Mode was reopened in Paris in May of 1990 at the Musee de Aute de la Mode.
这真是一场经典的改造蒙太奇。我其实有一本剪贴簿。我可以拿出来给你看。真的吗？是的，琳达几乎保留了每一份派对邀请函、每一份晚宴菜单。在她的剪贴簿里，有很多很多照片。琳达看起来像个超模。她高挑消瘦，留着金色的波波头，戴着三股珍珠颈链。手里总是拿着一杯饮料，因大笑而满面红光。时尚剧场于1990年5月在巴黎的高级时装博物馆重新开业。
It was a smash success. There were parties and photoshoots and press interviews and it was like Linda had gone through the looking glass. She was living the very fantasy that the Tiatradella mud represented. Case in point, back in Washington State, Linda had cut out an article from Vogue about the up-and-coming dress designer, Ervella J. And in Paris, Susan brought Linda to Ervella J's studio to get a dress fitted for her. It's simple, black and white with a drop waist.
这是一场轰动的成功。有派对、写真拍摄和媒体采访，就像琳达穿过了镜中世界。她过着时尚剧场所代表的那个幻想生活。比如，回到华盛顿州时，琳达从《Vogue》杂志上剪下了一篇关于新锐服装设计师埃尔维拉·J的文章。在巴黎，苏珊把琳达带到了埃尔维拉·J的工作室去试穿一件衣服。很简单，黑白相间，带有低腰设计。
In her blonde bob and her Ervella Jress, Linda looked like a 90s flapper. It was like a fairy tale, especially because this her veille de la gredress was for an actual ball. After France, the Tiatr d'Ella mode was exhibited at the costume institute at the Metropolitan Museum of Art, and it was on display during the MED Gala that year. And the MED Gala is just the fashion party. In 1990, Linda received an invitation. I was kind of be dazzled with the opportunity
顶着金色的波波头，穿着埃尔维拉·J的裙子，琳达看起来像个90年代的摩登女郎。这就像童话一样，尤其是因为这件埃尔维拉·J的裙子是为一场真正的舞会准备的。离开法国后，时尚剧场在纽约大都会艺术博物馆服装学院展出，并在那一年的慈善舞会期间展出。慈善舞会就是那个时尚派对。1990年，琳达收到了邀请。我简直被这个机会惊艳到了，
of going to this incredibly glamorous dinner party at the Met. Like, who would ever think that was gonna happen when I moved to Maryhill Museum in 1983? And I can't help but notice as the pictures in her scrapbook progress. Linda starts to look more and more like Susan. Somebody once laughed like,
能去大都会博物馆参加这场极其迷人的晚宴。天哪，谁能想到1983年我搬到玛丽希尔博物馆时会发生这种事？我忍不住注意到，随着她剪贴簿里的照片不断增加。琳达开始越来越像苏珊了。曾经有人嘲笑说，
oh Linda, you're Susan's little mannequin. Like, she's dressing you. She had opinions about how I looked. She did. And Eliza, do it a little way. Like, I can teach you how to be chic. Susan wanted to teach, and Linda wanted to learn. They were getting closer.
哦，琳达，你是苏珊的小模特。就像，她在给你打扮。她对我的外表很有看法。她确实有。安丽莎，稍微这样弄一下。就像，我可以教你如何变得时髦。苏珊想教，而琳达想学。他们的关系越来越近了。
We did love each other. We really did. We did love each other. We were very, very good friends. But Linda started imitating Susan in other ways too, less healthy ones. I'm sure she was naturally thin. So staying in that body that I had in Paris and New York
我们确实爱彼此。我们真的。我们确实爱彼此。我们是非常非常好的朋友。但琳达也开始以其他方式模仿苏珊，一些不太健康的方式。我确信她天生就很瘦。所以保持我在巴黎和纽约时拥有的那种身材
was really hard and took a lot of time. Linda was eating less and as she put it, exercising like a crazy person. And then you'd get back to Goldendale and you'd still be like running and dieting and... Yes, definitely. Really? Yeah. I didn't want to disappoint Susan.
真的很难，花了很多时间。琳达吃得越来越少，正如她所说，像个疯子一样锻炼。然后你回到戈尔登代尔，你仍然会像这样跑步和节食……是的，绝对会。真的吗？对。我不想让苏珊失望。
I know exactly what Linda is talking about. I think a lot of people do. There were years in my life where I tried to starve myself, and definitely a big part of it was I wanted to fit into beautiful clothing. And when you are intentionally starving yourself, that is a task that takes over your whole brain. I didn't think about anything else. It's not sustainable.
我完全明白琳达在说什么。我想很多人也是。我生命中曾有几年试图让自己挨饿，绝对很大一部分原因是我想要穿下漂亮的衣服。而当你刻意让自己挨饿时，那是一项会占据你整个大脑的任务。我什么都没想。这是不可持续的。
And it's not even very fun. Because you're constantly thinking, all the goddamn time about what you're gonna eat or not eat so your entire world Like it kind of pains me to think of those years like not thinking about other things but thinking about Acidously writing down every calorie in a little notebook in this condition You feel like you're not human like you can't eat meals and just enjoy life the way other people can. But I did it in pursuit of glamour, of something that ascends to a higher plane than normal life.
而且一点也不好玩。因为你一直在想，该死的一直在想你要吃什么或不吃什么，以至于你的整个世界……回想起那些年，我感到有点痛苦，没有去想别的事情，而是在一个小笔记本上刻板地记下每一卡路里。在这种状态下，你会觉得自己不像个人，你不能像其他人一样吃着饭并享受生活。但我追求的是魅力，一种超越普通生活、升华到更高层面的东西。
Something that's impossible. You can't stay this thin for that long. You can't. I mean, I couldn't. And it was, it created a real crisis of confidence. Even Susan could see that Linda wasn't doing well. She was a little worried about me at how thin I had become. And I remember at one lunch we were having lunch together and she insisted on getting a bowl of strawberries and whipped cream for dessert. And I
这是不可能的。你不可能这么瘦这么长时间。你做不到。我是说，我做不到。这引发了真正的自信危机。连苏珊也看出琳达状况不佳。她有点担心我变得这么瘦。我记得有一次我们一起吃午饭，她坚持要点一碗草莓配鲜奶油作为甜点。而我
remember her sitting there saying Linda eat. her sitting there saying, Linda, eat. After New York, the Tiatra Della mode went to Tokyo, and so did Linda. But in the pictures in her scrapbook, all the glamour appears to be taking a toll on her. She actually gained a lot of weight in only a few months from all the stress and traveling. And she was spending a lot of money.
记得她坐在那儿说，琳达，吃吧。她坐在那儿说，琳达，吃吧。离开纽约后，时装剧场（Tiatra Della mode）来到了东京，琳达也去了。但在她剪贴簿的照片中，所有那些光鲜亮丽似乎都开始对她产生负面影响。由于巨大的压力和奔波，她居然在短短几个月内胖了很多。而且她还花了很多钱。
Oh, I put myself into debt by chasing, like having to have the air veil, I don't regret it. It was really exciting to wear that dress for one night at the Costume Institute Gala. I would do it again. But it had major repercussions in my life that lasted for a long time. Financial repercussions. Financial repercussions?
哦，为了追逐潮流，比如为了买那个面纱，我欠下了债务，我不后悔。在服装学院慈善晚宴（Costume Institute Gala）上穿那件裙子真的很令人兴奋。我愿意再做一次。但它对我的生活产生了重大影响，持续了很长时间。财务影响。财务影响？
Financial repercussions? Body dysmorphia? Linda started to wonder exactly why she was doing all this. Like, how much did I want to be like Susan Train? I mean, Susan was in many ways a very lonely person. I didn't want to depend on anyone for anything. Susan Train told a Vogue journalist in 2007. I never wanted to be identified with one click.
财务影响？身体变形恐惧症？琳达开始琢磨，自己究竟为什么要搞这些。比如，我到底有多想成为苏珊·特兰（Susan Train）那样的人？我的意思是，苏珊在许多方面都是一个非常孤独的人。我不想在任何事情上依赖任何人。苏珊·特兰在2007年对一位《Vogue》记者说。我从来不想被归入某一个圈子。
The profile adds that Susan Train knew every designer, but kept a professional distance, and that she intentionally did not spend time with Americans. Linda, apparently, was an exception. Well, I learned that what appears to be very glamorous could be very lonely. In watching Susan Linda realize that she didn't want to be quite so addicted to her work or quite so lonely or quite so thin. And then the best possible thing happened.
该人物专访还提到，苏珊·特兰认识每一位设计师，但保持着职业距离，并且她刻意不和美国人交往。显然，琳达是个例外。嗯，我了解到，看似光鲜亮丽的事物背后可能会非常孤独。看着苏珊，琳达意识到她不想对工作如此上瘾，不想那么孤独，也不想那么骨感。然后，最好的一幕发生了。
The show ended. The Teatro della Mode went back to Mary Hill and so did Linda, back to her little house on the cliff. But this whirlwind experience made Linda ready to move on. She went to live in New York for a spell and then eventually went back west. And she lives in Portland now, and she spent much of her career working in museums and collections there. She can drive to the Mary Hill Museum of Art in two hours. And she does, every so often, to remember this beacon of hope for post-war France and this evidence of a parallel life she once had. Because the other witnesses
演出结束了。时装剧场回到了玛丽山（Mary Hill），琳达也回去了，回到了她悬崖边的小房子里。但这段旋风般的经历让琳达做好了继续前进的准备。她在纽约住了一阵子，最后又回到了西部。她现在住在波特兰，职业生涯的大部分时间都在那里的博物馆和藏品部门工作。她开车去玛丽山艺术博物馆只需要两个小时。她确实每隔一段时间就会去一次，去缅怀战后法国的这盏希望之灯，以及她曾经拥有过的平行生活的见证。因为其他的见证人
to her story are mostly gone. My husband John met Susan and went to France for honeymoon. If I went to Paris and it was so great to see Susan, we had meals together and it was the last time I saw her. Most of the artisans and experts and historians who were involved with the mannequins in both of their incarnations have passed away. In a lot of ways this story has become lindas. I'm kind of sick of people talking about like I, you know, I did this or I had this and it changed my life, it changed my life, changing experience.
关于她的故事的大多已经不在了。我丈夫约翰遇到了苏珊，并去法国度蜜月。如果我去巴黎，能见到苏珊真是太好了，我们一起吃饭，那是我最后一次见到她。那些曾参与这两个时期微型模特制作的工匠、专家和历史学家大都已去世。在很多方面，这个故事已经成了琳达自己的故事。我有点厌烦别人谈论，比如，你知道的，我做了这个，或者我拥有了这个，它改变了我的生活，它改变了我的生活，这是一次改变人生的经历。
This actually changed my life. It taught me lessons that I think about today. After our weekend together, Linda sent me a quote that she had heard a long time ago which had stayed with her. It was attributed to Ben Brantley, the theater critic for the New York Times. Glamour is whatever you can't have. It is best perceived at a distance, either literally or emotionally. Knowledge kills Glamour. This just seemed so utterly true to Linda. She experienced the shadow side of her jet-set life with Susan. She knew about the suffering and deep trauma behind the tiny mannequins.
这真的改变了我的生活。它教给我一些我至今仍在思考的道理。在我们度过周末后，琳达给我发了一句她很久以前听过并一直铭记在心的话。这句话归功于《纽约时报》戏剧评论家本·布兰特利（Ben Brantley）。魅力就是你无法拥有的一切。它最好在保持一定距离的情况下被感知，无论是字面意义上的还是情感上的。知识会杀死魅力。这对琳达来说简直是千真万确。她和苏珊一起体验了喷气机生活方式（jet-set life）阴暗的一面。她了解那些微型模特背后所承载的痛苦与深重创伤。
And yet, I personally don't know if knowledge kills Glamour entirely. Wounds it severely, for sure. But it's hard to completely destroy the illusion. The aspirational pull of fashion carves out a space in our imagination. It's why we dream of Paris, why we want to see Cardi B on the red carpet and vintage couture.
然而，我个人并不知道知识是否会彻底杀死魅力。毫无疑问，它给魅力带来了严重的创伤。但要完全摧毁这种幻觉是很困难的。时尚对人的吸引力在我们的想象中开辟了一片天地。这就是为什么我们梦想去巴黎，为什么我们想在红毯上看到卡迪·B（Cardi B）和复古高级定制服装。
Glamour involves so much delicate placement of smoking mirrors for the people who occupy that rarefied air. So much so that the pleasure in it is really ours. We, the viewing public, the audience. Linda knows this, and I think that's why she enjoys the show. I don't want to go anyplace else on the night of the Oscars.
对于身处那个极其稀有的高层世界的人来说，魅力涉及了太多对虚幻幻象（smoking mirrors）的精心布置。以至于其中的乐趣其实属于我们。我们，观看的公众，观众。琳达深知这一点，我想这也是她喜欢这个节目的原因。奥斯卡之夜我哪儿也不想去。
I want to be in front of my TV with absolute silence, and I just want to watch, but I don't want to be that. And I don't even want to be in that world. Not again. That once was enough. From the vantage point of Linda's living room, the beautiful people on TV seem so small and innocuous. They almost look like little dolls. The pockets are so beautiful. and innocuous. They almost look like little dolls. The pocket, the piece of paper, words from yesterday. There's a portrait painted on the things we love.
我想安安静静地坐在电视机前，我只想看着，但我不想成为那样的人。我甚至不想进入那个世界。一次就够了。从琳达的客厅望去，电视里那些光鲜亮丽的人显得那么渺小和无害。他们看起来几乎就像是小玩偶。那些口袋是如此美丽而无害。他们几乎看起来像小玩偶。口袋，那张纸，昨日的话语。在我们热爱的事物上，画着一幅肖像。
Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Truffleman, edited by Chris Baroube, scored by Ray Royal and Sean Raal. Fact checked by Tom Colligan with additional fact checking by Graham Haysha. Mix and Tech production by Sheree Fusef with additional mixing by Catherine Ray Mondo. Our opening and closing songs are by Sassami. Insight support and edits from the whole 99PI team, including Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh,
《感兴趣的物品》（Articles of Interest）由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）撰写并演说，克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Baroube）剪辑，雷·罗亚尔（Ray Royal）和肖恩·拉尔（Sean Raal）配乐。汤姆·科利根（Tom Colligan）核实事实，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）协助核实事实。混音与技术制作由谢里·富塞夫（Sheree Fusef）完成，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Catherine Ray Mondo）协助混音。我们的开场曲和闭幕曲由萨萨米（Sassami）创作。整个99PI团队提供了深刻支持和编辑，包括乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、
Abby Medallon, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle. And Roman Mars is the true fantasy of this whole series. In the first half of the 20th century, French high fashion was incredibly lucrative, but it's not as though Paris was making all that profit from the couple thousand women who could afford looks fresh off the runway. The big money maker was that department stores all over the world copied these looks and paid money to copy them. There was actually something to refer to as a licensed copy.
艾比·梅达隆（Abby Medallon）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。而罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）则是整个系列真正的幻想。在20世纪上半叶，法国高级时装极其赚钱，但并不是说巴黎的所有利润都来自那几千个买得起刚下T台的新款服装的女性。真正的大金主是，世界各地的百货公司都在抄袭这些款式，并付费购买抄袭权。实际上有一种东西被称为授权复制品。
So that was if you were a French couturier, you could sell a license to a design. Retailers like barnies or orbox or wool warts, big stores all over the world would buy sketches or patterns from French designers and recreate the outfits to sell in their shops. And the label would say like, do you buy Bergerff's? So there's various labels.
所以这就是，如果你是一个法国高级时装设计师，你可以出售设计的许可证。巴尼百货（Barneys）、博克思（Orbox）或伍尔沃斯（Woolworths）等零售商，世界各地的许多大商店都会从法国设计师那里购买草图或纸样，并在他们的店铺里重新制作服装进行销售。标签上会写着，比如，你买的是伯格多夫的吗？所以有各种各样的标签。
Ariel Alaya curated an exhibit about counterfeits at the Fashion Institute of Technology. And she showed me a label from one of these licensed copies. So in here it says, Bergerff Goodman on the Plaza, New York, and it has the customer's name, the date, which is 1949, and the serial number to this, because they were only able to do a certain amount of copies
阿里尔·阿莱亚（Ariel Alaya）在纽约时装学院（Fashion Institute of Technology）策划了一个关于假冒商品的展览。她向我展示了其中一件授权复制品的标签。所以这里写着，纽约广场上的伯格多夫·古德曼（Bergdorf Goodman），上面有顾客的姓名、日期（即1949年）以及序列号，因为他们只能制作一定数量的复制品。
that was in the licensing agreement. These licensed copies were nowhere near as expensive and rare as the original runway designs, but they were still to a lesser degree, expensive and rare. So a Couture like Dior, he made sure that there was only maybe five or ten of that piece reproduced, because you want to maintain the exclusivity. This system of licensed copies more or less ended by the 1970s.
这包含在许可协议中。这些授权复制品远没有原本的T台设计那么昂贵和稀有，但它们在较小程度上依然是昂贵且稀有的。因此，像迪奥（Dior）这样的大师，他会确保某个款式只被复制生产五到十件，因为你要保持排他性。这种授权复制品的体系在20世纪70年代前后基本结束了。
People didn't really care about wearing an entire designer outfit anymore, but they did still care about the clout of designers. You all of a sudden have it switched to more accessories. You have handbags and things like that. If you look at the 1980s with Logomania, that's where you start to see all of the monograms on the bags. Your next articles of interest are knockoffs. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人们不再真正在乎穿一整套设计师设计的衣服，但他们仍然在乎设计师带来的影响力。你突然发现重心转向了更多的配饰。你有手袋之类的东西。如果你看看20世纪80年代的标志狂热（Logomania），那就是你开始在包包上看到各种各样的花押字的地方。你接下来的感兴趣的物品是仿冒品。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。